Let’s talk now about how we would actually
apply the kernel to an image.
What is the algorithm that we would need to
apply?
And this is what it looks like; it is a summation
over the input window which is designated
by the symbol W. And inside the summation
we have the input image I and the kernel K.
The indices I and J both range over values
from -H to +H. What we have written here mathematically
is the definition of a two dimensional correlation.
There is a related operation called convolution,
and 2D convolution is represented mathematically
this way.
It is very similar to the correlation we just
looked at; in fact, the only differences are
these negative signs here.
For correlation they were positive signs.
Now convolution is the same as correlation
if the kernel is symmetric.
The Gaussian kernel we just looked at, for
example, is indeed symmetric.
An advantage of convolution is that it can
be written in operator form.
So what this says is the output image is equal
to the kernel convolved with the input image
I.
So the symbol of a cross inside a circle represents
the operation of convolution.
What are some of the properties of convolution?
Well for a start it is commutative, so A convolved
with B is the same as B convolved with A.
It is also associative and this is a property
that we will use in some upcoming slides.
We say it is distributive.
And it is also linear.
So these are important mathematical properties
of convolution.
Now, what are the advantages of associativity?
Well consider the case where I convolve an
image with a Gaussian and then I convolve
with a Gaussian again.
So if you like, I can think of this as adding
an image, I smooth it by applying a Gaussian
to it and then I smooth it again.
This is the same as convolving the image with
a kernel which is the Gaussian convolved with
itself.
And convolving a Gaussian with another Gaussian
results in a Gaussian.
And the standard deviation of the result Gaussian
is a function of a standard deviation of the
two Gaussians that are multiplying, as shown
over here on the left.
So in order to convolve an image with a very
large Gaussian which would require a very
big kernel, it is actually equivalent to convolving
the image with a small Gaussian multiple times
consecutively.
And there may be some computational advantages
of doing that.